Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I have several life updates to do.
Also, if I sound... I did have a little session with my sound team today, earlier today.
So I might sound a little different again.
Every stream in the last three days, I sound a little different.
But like, each day is an improvement.
So I had like a session.
I have a pop filter now.
So now, now when I say pepperoni pizza, my pop sound, it's not as popping as it was before.
So it doesn't pound like I'm popping at you, right?
Pound!
My pops!
Give my pepperoni pizza pops!
Oh shit.
Preposterous!
So I got my pop filters now.
Anyway, this is one life update.
Do you remember when I said I was never going to order from overheat?
Okay, so I forgot to do grocery shopping today.
You know, like getting my groceries delivered today.
I forgot to do that.
So today I have to order Uber Eats.
And so I forgot about, you know, being like, I will never do it again because of all these problems.
These problems that I've been having.
And then, so I was like, you know what?
I'll do it.
It's just going to be one order.
It's the weakest boycott ever.
So I was like, all right, I'll just order it.
I'll order groceries for tomorrow for it to arrive.
So I ordered it from this sushi place that I really like.
And I was so looking forward to it because it's like really, it's a really good place.
And I ordered a bento box that was $45.
And I was like, so looking forward to it because it has some like nice, bougie shit in that bento box.
Some like nice, bougie rolls in there.
So I was like, ooh, okay, I really want to try this bento box.
And so I was like, you know, I'm going to treat myself.
I'm going to treat myself because the last couple of days, um, so like I've been like trying to be on a strict, like a healthier eating schedule.
So like today, I was like, you know what, I'm going to treat myself and order something nice.
Because the last couple of days, I've just been eating like bread.
I was eating, I've been eating a slice of bread.
Cover it with brie, like, you know, like I use a brie cheese spread on it.
Um, and, uh, you put like, you know, turkey, a turkey slice or like chicken slice.
And then I'm like, um, that's my meal for the day.
Like that, not the day, for that, I'll eat like one slice for a meal.
And I'll be like, um, all right, that's good enough.
That's, not a day, but like, you know, I'd be like, all right, that's lunchtime.
Or I eat salad.
I have salad too.
So I would be like, all right, salad.
So I've been doing that for like the last like two weeks or so.
Or like, well, not every day.
You know, I would have like, you know, cheat days where I'd be like, okay, let me have something not healthy.
And... I'm trying to change my living... living life, okay?
I'm trying to be more healthy.
Guys, okay.
Also, I might have, like, splurged a little bit.
Because I got... I was like, I need to start moving more.
But I don't want to go outside.
Or go downstairs to my apartment gym.
So I bought myself a... a exercise bike.
Even though I have a gym that's, like, just in... just, like, below me.
Um... I wanna... exercise more.
But, like, I don't wanna go downstairs.
I... I don't wanna go downstairs.
There's so many people downstairs, too.
I don't want them to, like... I don't know.
I don't wanna watch me.
Or some shit.
It's weird.
I... So... I bought an exercise bike, too.
I have to, like... It's still outside.
They delivered it this morning.
It's still outside my door.
Along with the doggy gate.
That I still have yet to... Nice.
Along with the... Along with the giant doggy gate box.
That I also still have yet to, like...
Still have yet to bring inside.
It's been out there for, like, at least a week now.
I think, like, almost two weeks now.
But, like, it's still there.
Um...
But now the exercise bike is also out there, too.
I... I swear to God.
I'll... I'll bring one of them in.
Most likely the exercise bike.
And have to piece it together.
It was like...
Do you wanna pay $90 to have someone assemble it for you?
And then I looked at the thing.
I was like...
Easily assembled.
And I was like...
I can do that.
But first I need to bring it inside.
I'll worry about that later.
I'll...
I was like...
I can do that.
I'm just gonna...
I'll bring that in another time.
Um...
It literally said 30 minutes to assemble.
I...
They're like...
It only takes 30 minutes to assemble.
And I was like...
You know what?
That sounds like something I can do.
Um...
But yes.
I also bought an exercise bike.
Cause I was like...
I should, you know, move more.
Be a little bit more healthier.
I don't wanna go downstairs.
Uh...
But...
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna go downstairs.
But...
I wanna exercise in the comfort of my own apartment.
So...
So I bought one.
Um...
You know what's crazy?
I also have a treadmill.
I haven't used that in a while.
But I was like...
You know what?
I like biking more than running.
So I was like...
Okay.
I'm definitely more motivated to bike than I am to run.
So like...
I feel like it'll be better.
I feel like...
Because I think I bike more than I run.
And...
You know what's crazy?
I used to have an exercise bike when I lived with my parents.
And then I got the treadmill.
Because I was like...
I'm gonna run more than I bike.
But now...
So then my parents got rid of the treadmill.
Oh no.
Got rid of the biking...
Bike one.
So like...
I don't know what happened to the bike one.
So now I'm like...
You know what?
I think I bike more than I run.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get that.
You're a mess.
I don't know.
Maybe as I got older...
I was like...
No.
I definitely like biking more than riding.
Right?
Meaning...
Yeah.
So...
Yes.
Anyway.
Sorry.
What was I talking about before I got into...
What was I talking about before I got...
I got distracted about my...
The exercise bike.
Oh yeah.
The Uber Eats story.
So...
Two laundry dry racks.
Thank you for this super chat.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Sorry.
My original story.
About the...
I like how I'm dropping all of this...
On the Dynasty Warriors stream too.
So not a lot of people are gonna hear this story.
People are really missing out.
I drop all the...
I always drop the most interesting stories...
During the Dynasty Warriors streams.
D-Dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Doki.
At this point, I think you...
Get out from us judging you...
On your life choices.
Black.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As a mountain biker, biking is great.
Even when you're confronted with your own mortality.
After...
Jesus Christ.
That sounds fucking scary.
Um...
After you make a mistake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Oh yeah.
Uh...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Okay.
So...
So I was like...
Okay.
I'm gonna order from the sushi place.
Because...
Also like...
By the way...
Sorry.
Another off topic.
Um...
Because I noticed it's flickering.
My third monitor...
The monitor where you guys live in...
Where I look at chat...
Is dying apparently.
Um...
I did own this monitor for like...
Five plus years now.
So like...
Um...
It's like flickering...
On and up.
So I might have to like...
Use two monitors for now.
I might have to...
I might have to live my...
Oh!
I have to look at the left side.
It's so weird.
I'm not used to looking at the...
The thing is...
My monitor is like flicking...
I do have another spare monitor.
But monitors are so fucking heavy though.
Oh!
It's so weird having like...
Two monitors.
Um...
Because like...
I like...
It's so weird looking at left side...
Instead of right side...
For my chat.
Um...
But yes.
It's flickering.
It's not the cable.
By the way.
It's...
I...
Tested it.
I mean...
I could try the HDMI cable.
Let me try that real quick guys.
I'm just gonna push it in a little bit.
See if it's the...
HDMI cable.
Ugh!
Okay.
It's like all pushed really in.
I might have to hire a handyman to fix this.
I...
Okay.
So...
My third monitor...
The weird thing is...
Is that...
Um...
The really weird thing is that...
Uh...
When I restart my PC...
And...
Uh...
When I...
When I have to restart my PC...
Or...
When I turn my monitor on and off...
It's okay.
So I don't think it's a cable issue.
Because it's okay.
Until like...
Uh...
Like a couple of minutes.
Like maybe 10 to 15 minutes.
And it starts flickering again.
So I assume...
It's like...
I assume that it's just my monitor is dying.
It's at the end of its lifespan.
Right now.
So...
Um...
So I think that's...
Why...
That's...
So I...
Like...
And then like...
I do have a spare monitor.
But like...
It's so heavy.
It's so fucking heavy.
So I'm like...
Um...
Yeah.
So I'm just like...
Oh...
I don't wanna...
You know...
Plug the monitor.
And like...
Plug in the new monitor.
So I might...
I have to...
Oh my god.
It's so heavy for me.
Uh...
Um...
So yeah.
I don't know.
Anyway.
Sorry.
The Uber Eats order.
Back to the Uber Eats story.
So...
Um...
I ordered my thing.
And I was so excited for it.
And then when I arrived...
I was like...
Why is it two boxes?
And then when I opened the first...
And I was like...
Why did you give me Coke?
Because I ordered a...
Japanese drink.
And then I got Coke.
So I was like...
Why did I get...
Why did I get Coke?
And why is there two boxes?
So I opened the two boxes up.
It's clearly...
Not a bento box.
Because it was like...
One of them was like...
Like...
Sushi.
But...
And it was like...
You know...
Sushi order.
The other one was also sushi order.
But I was like...
Wait.
Wait, but my bento box should have sashimi and all that shit on it and sushi, too.
And then so I was like, and this was obviously cheaper than what the fuck I ordered because I ordered sashimi in it.
So I was like, okay, what the fuck is going on?
And I looked at the box.
So, okay, so let me tell you, the name on the order...
So I'm DokiBird, right?
So, like, just imagine, okay, the name of the order is, like, DokiBird, but it was, like...
Just think that, instead of it being DokiBird, it's, like, DokiBirdy.
Or DokiBread, or some shit.
So I was like, what the...
It's like, yeah, DokiPird.
Just think, like, it's just, like, DokiPird.
Because I was like, wait a minute.
Not only is my first name spelled wrong, but my...
That's not even my last name's initial.
Like...
So...
Someone else had a similar name as mine, but it was spelled wrong?
And it's also, like, not my initial for my last name.
So I...
So I was like, how the fuck did I get...
I got somebody else's order.
I literally got somebody else's order.
I was...
But it was, like, the names were...
It's, like, the parallel universe of my name.
And...
I was so upset, because I was like,
clearly more expensive.
They got the better meal!
Like...
They got...
They actually got the better meal.
My...
My bento box had fucking lobster!
I had lobster in my order!
And sashimi!
I had a lobster roll!
No, I...
I...
I reported it.
And they're like, oh yeah, they processed a refund.
They already processed a refund.
It should show up.
Um...
It should show...
It should show up in, like, a couple of days.
But, like, I didn't know...
The guy was gone!
But I, like...
Obviously, I had, like, stuff to do.
So I was like...
I'm gonna finish my stuff real quick.
And then, like, I'm gonna...
Oh my god, it's flickering again.
Oh, it's flickering again.
Yeah, I'm gonna look at...
I'm gonna turn this monitor off.
I cannot deal with the flickering.
Right?
Um...
Cause I have, like...
Cause, like, you know, seizure warning and shit like that.
Uh...
So I can't...
I'm, like, worried about shit like that.
Um...
But I...
I couldn't believe it!
I was like...
They can't fuck it up a fourth time.
There's no way...
How bad could my luck be...
That they would fuck it up a fourth time?
Hehehehe...
I...
I couldn't believe it!
Um...
Roy...
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
Um...
I'll top it.
What do you think about...
Ultron in Marvel Rivals?
If you saw the release of the trailer?
Oh!
He seems really strong!
I was told that he's most likely gonna be, like, the third support.
So, like, most DPS players are gonna be playing him.
Or, like, in competitive-wise.
Cause he's...
He'll be, like, the Atom.
Where you run a third...
Third support.
Like, the old...
Or the old Jeff.
Cause they re...
They nerfed him.
Like, they, like, reworked Jeff to be more of a healer.
So Ultron might be, like, the new Jeff.
Um...
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should get a new MSI monitor.
That's the thing.
I have one of the MSI monitors there.
But it's...
It's just, like, my arms are so noodley when it comes to, like, carrying things.
So...
By the way.
Um...
I am done rage baiting people by, uh...
Playing mouse and keyboard on...
For Elden Ring.
Because after that, my wrists got tired.
My wrists were sore after that.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna play on controller.
Um...
I can't...
My...
I can't believe it.
I am able to play 12 plus hours of Marvel Rivals M&K.
But, like, my...
My...
My wrists actually got tired in Elden Ring.
It was like...
It got...
Actually got sore.
So...
I was like...
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna play controller on the second part.
I...
I can't...
I can't deal with that.
Uh...
That's...
I rage baited my wrists.
Yeah.
Um...
I wanted a rage bait, but...
I ended up fucking myself over.
That's crazy.
Uh...
Papa Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This dope won't burn me for fourth time.
Doki probably.
Um...
So yeah.
Oh...
That's...
So that's what happened.
Um...
I just can't believe I got fucked over fourth time.
Also...
Another...
I'll give you guys a dad update.
Um...
So...
Dad update.
Um...
So...
I've been taking him to the dog park instead of like walking him the usual road.
Because like I said, he hates harnesses.
And...
Um...
Dad hates harnesses.
Doki Amber Doge hates harnesses.
And also...
They somehow got rid of all the trash cans.
On my walk.
I don't know why.
Like...
Ever since like he broke his back.
You know, obviously I haven't been walking him.
But during the span of him breaking his back.
And...
Um...
Going...
You know, staying at the pet sitter.
The trash cans disappear.
So...
So I was like...
I'm never...
I'm not gonna take him...
Off there anymore.
So...
And then like...
I'm not...
I don't wanna bring the trash...
His poops...
Back to my place.
And then throw it in my own garbage.
Like I feel like...
I don't know...
I just think that's fucking weird.
So, somehow, all the trashcans disappear.
The closest trashcan, like, is outside, is, like, a lot further away.
So, I was just like, I'm not walking that far.
Like, because I have to walk him three times a day.
And I was like, okay, yeah, I'm not doing that.
So, I had to take him to, like, my dog park area.
But, like, it's, like, near my... it's, like, sort of, like, near my apartment building.
So, I, like, I don't have to actually go outside.
Like, my apartment, like, leads to the dog park.
But it's, like, it's, like, a miniaturized thing.
It's not, like, a big dog park or anything.
It's, like, a miniaturized thing.
And, um...
And so, like, so, when I walk there, because I can walk inside my apartment to get to the dog park, um...
It's, like, yeah, it feels less hygienic.
I don't know.
It's, like, I mean, you need to clean it.
But, like, obviously, it smells not great.
I would say that, like, the dog park doesn't smell the greatest, but, um, anyway, um, when we, like, walked there, um, okay, so there was, it's not indoors, it's outside, but it's, like, artificial grass and stuff, so, um, so, okay, when we walked there,
because we have to, like, we have, there's a pathway from the apartment complex to there, um, and, um, I think it's artificial grass, I'm not totally sure, but the grass does not look real.
I, I don't want to touch it, because all the dogs have been, like, pooping and peeing on it, so, I'm not gonna, I, I'm not gonna touch it.
Like, to, like, make sure it's real grass.
Like, so, I assume it's, I assume it's artificial, because it looks artificial to me.
Anyway, um, so, like, we passed, I, when I was walking him there, it was, like, some pugs walking, like, on the opposite side, directly towards me, and then, dad, like, looked at them, and then he looked at me, and he's, like, pick me up.
So, dad was, like, okay, okay, because he was, like, walking, he was, like, pick me up, and I was, like, okay.
I was bent down, he instantly, like, got in my arms, and in a moment, I picked him up, he just starts barking at the pugs.
I... I was like, what the fuck?
He's just like, that's right.
Get, move!
Get outta here!
He's like, yeah, he's like, I need to have the high ground if I'm gonna challenge him.
I was like, I was like, you pussy-ass bitch.
Like, you needed me to pick you up before you fucking bark at them.
I have the high ground.
I was like, that's right, bitch.
Move!
And then another thing that happened was that this was yesterday.
This was yesterday.
When I went to the dog park, there was a pretty lady there.
And dad was so excited.
But the pretty lady had, like, her own small dog.
And then also a big dog with her that's walking around.
So she had, like, this small dog with her in her arms.
And dad walked over there and he was like, yes, pay attention to me!
And he's like, yes!
And he's, like, clawing her leg and everything.
And obviously the small dog got really jealous.
And was trying to, like, bark at him.
And he's like, get out of here!
This is my owner!
And the other big dog also got really mad, too.
And he was, like, trying to, like, push her in my way.
He was like, yeah!
This is our owner!
And he ignored them.
And was like, yes!
Pay attention to me!
Yes!
And then the owner was like, is he always like this?
And I was like, um, not...
I didn't want to say only to women.
But, like, I was like, not really.
Because I was like...
And then, like, I would push him away.
And I would, like, take him to, like, the other side of the field.
And then he would, like, um...
He would, like, run back to her.
It was crazy.
He kept running back to her every time.
And, like, and then, like, he was like, no.
And then he was like...
And then she...
The owner thought that he was just interested in the smaller dog.
So she was like, oh, you want to play with the smaller dog, right?
So she put down the smaller dog.
And then he didn't give a fuck.
He didn't give a fuck about the other dog.
He was like, yes, now that that dog's out of the way.
Pick me up!
And...
And then, so, so, obviously, like, he was like, oh, you're not interested.
Okay, I'm just gonna hold my other small dog back.
And he just kept, like, like, looking at her and kept clawing her, pawing her and stuff, pawing on her legs and everything, just trying to, like, get his attention.
So now it's like, okay, you're clearly not gonna poop, right?
So, I was trying to get him to poop, but he clearly was not gonna poop.
So I had to pick him up.
And I was like, alright, it's over.
We're going home.
And then I, like, went out.
And obviously he isn't leashed or harnessed because, like, he doesn't like harnesses and stuff.
I don't wanna, like, force him.
And I'm not allowed to use the, uh, to use, like, a leash on his neck.
So then he just follows me around.
But then, like, because of that lady, I was like, you know, I was like, come on, let's go.
And then he, like, walks back to the door and just looks out the door, trying to find her.
And he refuses to move.
I was like, Doki, Doki, come on.
Come on, Doki, come on.
And he just, like, stands there just looking outside.
Because it's a seafood door.
He's just, like, looking outside.
And he's like, where is she?
And then I picked him up.
I picked him up.
I walked all the way to the... I walked all the way... down the hallway.
And then... I walked down the hallway to, like, try to get away from that dog park door.
And then, like... And then he runs back to the door.
Like, I put him down because I had to get my keys and stuff to, like, access my apartment complex.
And I put him down, and then he runs back to the door.
And I was just like, what the fuck?
He knows what he wants.
I don't know why.
He was so obsessed with her.
He's never done that before.
He would, you know, every time, like, you know, I let him...
Like, I was like, alright, it's time to go home.
He would walk, he would, like, just lead himself to back home.
And then he just runs back to the door, and he's like, where is she?
Where is she?
That's the love of my life right there.
So I had to walk back, pick him up again, and then just, like, had him in my arms while I walk home.
Like, because he wouldn't...
Every time, like, I try to be like, okay, I'll put you down.
And then he'll, like, turn around and start going back.
And I was just like, okay, you're not allowed to touch the ground anymore.
You're not allowed until we're home.
I...
Maybe I'll see her again.
So, so I don't trust him.
I don't trust him anymore.
I mean, and then, like, after that, the next walk, he was fine.
He was totally fine.
And then the day after that, he was totally fine.
Yeah, no, he's fucking neutered.
Of course he's neutered.
Like, I...
So, yeah, and then, and then he was, and then he's, like, fine on the next walk.
And the walk after that, I was like, what the fuck?
Like, what's wrong with you?
Like, like...
I had to follow your heart.
No, she's gone forever.
I hope I never see her again.
I...
That's right.
I said it.
Also, I need to be left side doki.
I almost forgot.
All right.
Left side doki.
Get out right side doki.
It's time.
Was I left side doki last time I streamed?
I don't know.
I've been so all over the place.
Let me double check.
I'm actually curious.
Was I on left side the last time I streamed Dynasty Warriors?
Because I feel like I was.
Oh, no.
I was.
All right.
I was on left side.
Yes.
Left side.
Maybe the last time you'll ever see left side doki.
It's so weird, guys.
It's so weird having my chat on the left monitor.
Because I'm not used to looking on the left side for chat.
Oh, I don't know if I like it.
I don't know.
I don't know if I like this.
All right.
Momo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got the higher ground now.
I'm superior.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Speaking of Eldering, as someone who was a Vodgoon for it, I really enjoyed your playthrough no matter how dumb it got.
Missing your souls playthrough and looking forward to part two.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you guys have been enjoying Eldering.
You know my manager?
He was like, thank God.
Stream more of those games.
He's like, I'm glad you're finally finishing Dynasty Warriors.
Stream more of those, stream more of those other games.
Alright, alright, it's time to see it.
He's like, I'm so fucking happy you're finally finishing Dynasty Warriors.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, by the way, I didn't realize I've been streaming Dynasty Warriors for like four months now.
And now I understand.
I understand now.
I didn't even realize it's been four months since I started.
That's actually crazy.
I didn't know I've been streaming this for so long.
That's insane.
Alright, hope you're grounded.
Flint and Steel off stream to start the fire at TV.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Manny, I'm sad.
Left side.
Toki is graduating.
Wishing her a good future.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Alright.
I can't believe it too.
I was surprised.
I was like, oh my God.
Has it really been that long?
Alright, let's see.
Okay, I need...
Okay, so I actually got a tier list out.
Okay, I need... Bursting Waste Slash.
A... Azer Dragon Bellow.
And Great Mountain Throw.
What the fuck are all those?
Okay.
Bursting Waste Slash.
Dragon.
Okay, Azer.
Dragon Bellow.
And look, we...
We need as much anything.
We...
We're fucking min-maxing, guys.
I'm done.
I'm so done.
Do you have the Great Mountain?
What the fuck is the Great Mountain?
Guys, I...
I cannot.
You guys saw how fucked up that was.
That level was so fucked up.
Okay, I don't have Great Mountain.
Whatever.
Okay, and then...
Whoops.
Get back on my horse.
Okay.
And then...
We need to have actual items now.
Okay, I have Strength Potion.
Guys, look at that.
I bought items.
I...
Guys, look at that.
I bought items.
That's how desperate I was in fucking beating this fight.
Look at that.
I'm literally...
I am literally six levels ahead.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
I'm...
I...
Oh my God.
I fought sick...
I leveled up so much.
No, you don't understand.
This...
I'm going alone.
Because like...
You don't understand.
This battle is so brutal.
Everyone around me kept fucking dying.
I don't know what to do.
I...
They were all dying.
Like...
I don't know what to do.
Alright, you have to tell me when the wind changes, guys.
I cannot think for myself right now.
I...
For the sake of our inalienable ambitions.
Oh my God.
I already almost fucked it up.
We must take command of this battle.
I cannot think for myself.
Like, I need you guys to think for me when the wind changes.
No, you guys have to...
Or we're gonna ha...
Or we're gonna be playing Dynasty Warriors until the end of time.
I cannot.
Like...
Every...
Every stream will just be the battle of Chibi.
I swear to God.
I...
This...
This stream will never end.
Repel the hostile offensive.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm okay.
Our chance of victory remains.
Yippee!
You're right.
I should've asked this in the community.
I should've asked that in a...
In a different stream.
Because I forgot.
All you hear that stuck through the entire Dynasty Warriors playthrough.
You won it.
I forgot.
You guys all won that.
I...
Alright.
How do I...
Guys, I don't remember how to...
Okay, this is bad.
How do I lock in?
I don't remember, guys.
Oh, it's been too long.
I actually don't remember.
Oh wait, it's this.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
We're good.
We're good to go.
Take that.
Okay.
One down.
Has been defeated.
With all my might.
Boom!
I missed it somehow.
But that's okay.
Concentrate.
Because I have this move too.
Okay.
If I could test my skills.
There you go.
Oh my god.
This is actually...
We're actually improving.
Has been defeated.
That is actually so good.
Oh my god.
Take that.
Thank god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I just have to leave.
Sorry.
I'm gonna leave now.
I'm gonna leave.
You guys can deal with it.
I have to go to the other side.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I've lost track of how to get to the others.
It's...
I'm doing great.
But I'm also like...
Not okay.
I'm hitting everything.
Alright.
Oh.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have to head to the other side now.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
We're heading to the other side.
Goodbye.
My people need me.
Everybody here is so fucking weak.
So far.
I'd say it's just about time to land another blood.
I'm running as fast as I can.
No!
Oh no.
The other people are here too.
Damn.
When did they get behind us?
I don't know.
But I have to...
This just became a lot more complicated.
I'm fucking right.
Oh my god.
How are you already fucking dead?
How?
How are you dead?
How...
Deal with the ambush first.
It's too late.
I'm already on the other side.
It's too fucking late.
I made it to the other side.
My strength was not enough.
We must maintain a constant...
It's already too late.
I'm already here.
Keep the enemy reinforcements at bay.
To protect our archers.
Please.
Duel me.
Oh my god.
I need every duel I could get.
Here you go.
Okay.
That's fine.
Time to act.
Luckily I just got that.
Check that.
Whirl.
Yes.
Let's go.
Easy.
That's right.
My.
Easy.
Please.
I need all of you guys to...
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Oh, that was a crit dodge.
I was like...
What?
That didn't register.
I should have registered.
Easy.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm locked in guys.
I'm so locked in.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
You may not be able to make it through this.
No.
Don't say that.
I'm doing everything I can.
Okay.
I'm gonna kill one more guy.
Maybe next time.
I'm gonna kill one more.
It's time.
Before I go to the other side again.
I'm...
heading...
for the altar.
Oh my god.
Please.
Alright.
I'm done.
Goodbye.
No.
I gotta go to the other side.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Time to go to the other side now.
Nice.
Alright.
Other side.
My people need me.
My other people need me now.
Please.
Live.
I'm coming.
Jumping over!
No!
Live!
Please!
Please, I'm almost there!
Eat as much bread as you can!
Please!
Even my horse is so leveled up!
Oh my god, I swear to god.
I swear to fucking god!
Jesus!
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
There we go.
We will now begin the prayer.
Jesus Christ.
We must distract the enemy while carrying out the most vital part of the plan.
Fire!
Bring them down.
I know this will be hard, but... I am counting on you all.
Losing Lord Chugo Liang means losing this battle.
We will not lose this!
I'm doing everything I can!
Please!
Jesus Christ, I don't know how I actually... Are you fucking kidding me?!
Are you fucking... Oh my god.
That's it!
I'm using strength now!
I'm so strong now!
You have to endure their assault for now.
I think that's strength, right?
Yeah, that is.
Oh my god, please!
I killed so many!
Please!
The battle is more intense than I anticipated.
Oh my god, let's get serious.
And I will continue to fight without complaint.
Okay.
We've lost our archers in the east.
You've lost your archers?!
How?!
The enemy's offensive will go on unimpeded now.
Oh no.
Oh no, I'm trying to kill him first!
I need to kill him!
That's it!
Things don't look too good!
Okay.
That should kill him!
Come on!
I will use this too!
That should kill both of them!
Oh my god, okay, they're down!
Alright!
Alright, we got that down!
Okay!
Alright, we go back!
We have to go to the other side!
Okay, Sun Qian!
Okay!
These guys are like, fairly anything.
I don't understand how you can die to this.
Alright, I'm going to the other side!
Goodbye!
The enemy officer has been defeated!
Annihilate the enemy with our fleet!
Wait, actually, I'll kill him first too!
Alright, goodbye!
I leave!
Goodbye!
I have to go to the other side!
I leave!
Oh no!
Goodbye!
My other people need me too!
That's stupid!
Ah, Sky!
I can't!
I believe on my team!
I believe my team!
I believe in my team!
I believe in them!
I have to do this first!
I lack the foresight to predict his betrayal!
Okay!
And stop him here!
Alright!
Okay, run!
Come!
Show you!
Of this point, there's nothing left to say!
Okay!
We got him!
Go, Drakos!
Okay, nice!
Jesus Christ!
Please!
We should send the rear guard to bolster our defenses there!
Oh my god!
This!
She said we can't lose!
How did you die?!
I was right there!
I don't...
Did you die?!
We were all here together!
The enemy has breached the altar room!
What?!
Oh shit!
Alright, I'll be right back!
Sorry, I gotta go!
Oh shit!
I gotta go!
I'll be right back!
I have to...
I have to go to the altar room now!
I'll be right back!
I'll be right back, everyone!
Please!
Okay!
Eat some bread!
So I can go get to the altar room!
Yeah!
You've rushed in to aid me!
Yes!
You're fine!
I swear!
Please don't make me cry more!
I swear to god!
Dude!
Have you sensed any changes in the wind?
I don't know!
Guys!
Please tell me, has there been changes in the wind?
Please!
I don't know!
I can't tell!
I've been trying to figure this out!
How?!
Why is the wind?!
Be warned!
I shall not hold back!
Oh my god!
How did he get there?!
Jesus!
Please!
Win!
Change!
Okay!
How did this guy get here?!
I know it, but he's desperate!
I'm doing my best!
James is holding a best!
But South-South forces still have the edge!
Go be, please!
Please, you have to live!
You have to live!
Wind, please, just change!
Let's go!
Let's get this!
Wind, just change!
Okay, I got him!
Such great strength.
Why won't the wind change?
I don't understand!
Please, change!
Wind!
Why won't you change?
Oh my god, Lube!
Just live!
Please, Lube!
Please!
Oh no!
Guys, I think it's over.
I think it's over.
I don't jump in!
I'm doing my best!
Guys!
Guys, did the wind change?
The wind still hasn't changed!
I don't understand!
No!
Why hasn't the wind changed?
I don't understand!
Okay.
What if we let Guan Yun fight Xiaohu Dun, and then we go back home?
Okay, I have an idea.
Let's go.
I go back now.
Oh shit!
I'm going to... I'm going to... I'm going back.
Okay.
Guan Yun will deal with Xiaohu Dun, and then I go to Lube.
I go to Lube.
There's no way.
I saved Lube.
The wind keeps taking its time!
Like, I don't know what to do!
This...
This is tough.
But they won't take any damage.
Why won't people do me?
I'm trying... Let me in!
You have to let me in!
No way.
I'm gonna lose.
Ah!
They blocked the door!
How did he get in?
So Hong Guy has retreated.
Oh my god, there they are!
Oh my god!
Let me through!
No!
Oh, it's okay!
Holy shit!
There's so many people!
Oh my god, don't wonder he died!
No wonder!
There's... Okay, I understand how he died.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so dead.
I'm actually so dead.
Oh my god, thank you!
What?
I died anyway!
There's no way!
Oh my god!
That's not looking good.
I just...
And he died!
Oh my god!
Okay.
That's fine.
We can do this again.
I think if I just defend...
It's normal!
That's the fucked up part!
This is normal difficulty!
Like I don't understand how my team is struggling!
Oh my god.
Come on!
Okay.
I'm trying... I don't understand why you closed... Why are these guards not helping you?
Why are your guards not helping you?
I don't understand!
Okay.
There you go!
Oh my god, Lupe was literally 180.
That's actually crazy.
Lupe was actually 1 HP there.
You should fall back and regroup.
Oh my god.
He was actually 1 HP.
I got this!
Everything is lining up perfectly.
Oh yeah!
You think it's lining up perfectly?
How do you think it's lining up perfectly?
We're all dying!
The enemy officer...
Why would you think it's perfect?
Everyone is dying!
The enemy officer is coming to help.
Thank you for coming.
Why would you think that?
No way.
I'm gonna lose.
Okay.
Alright.
One guy has appeared!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Ice!
Oh no.
There we go.
Here we go.
Okay, we'll defeat one more!
I'm gonna defeat one more!
And then I'm coming back!
Alright!
There's no way!
You're gonna struggle against Jeng Liao.
Alright!
We go back!
Oh my god!
Please!
I killed them all!
Oh my god!
We gotta go back!
We gotta make it back!
Jukollin!
Don't die!
Do not die!
Jukollin!
Oh no!
We're here for you!
Do not die!
The wind is already beginning to change.
It has!
Oh my god!
Please for the love of god!
Please!
Please hold on for a little longer!
I'm actually almost there!
Please for the love of god!
Just hold out!
For just a little longer!
Has it changed?
Oh my god!
It's changed!
We gotta go to the tower!
Jukollin!
Live!
I swear!
It's changed!
How do I light the fire?
How do I light it?
Not good.
How do I light the fire?
I don't know how!
Oh my god!
Light it!
This is our chance.
There you go!
This is it!
Let the plan lead us down the path to victory.
I'm pretty sure I didn't fuck it up.
Oh!
The signal!
Whoop!
Welcome to the tomato fire!
Welcome!
I live!
Why?
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
This fight!
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
A lovely wind!
Thank you!
That's right!
Just keep streaming at the wind!
That will convince it!
If I yell at the...
If I yell in the sky loud enough...
They will...
It will happen!
I should've shot arrows at the wind!
I should've shot arrows in the sky!
Maybe they'll change the wind!
Give that you've been willing to oppose even allies in the name of Wu!
Everyone would find her defection believable!
But...
Doing this will result in much grief for you, Lord HuangGai!
Are you still willing?
Hmph!
I don't know how you can...
I...
Trying to beat this level on heart must be like...
My train...
Is more painful...
Than a thousand...
Like...
People who chat...
Beat this level on heart...
Are you okay?
However...
It is even worse to fail to protect...
My...
No!
I...
I'm definitely not okay!
Lord Soto!
This is where you...
And I part ways!
So please accept this...
Grand apology!
These flames are...
The roar of Ooze!
Counterattack!
Yeah!
Finally!
Jesus Christ!
But like...
90% of them aren't even on boats!
Like I...
The  of oil episodes!
The only worst part!
Is just the factor!
The majority of these people are not even on boats!
So like...
I don't know...
I...
I don't know how...
Okay...
We are back on track!
Where did you- Where?
Where are you shoot- Hiiiiitkk...
ridership...
...90% of them are already at my base!
Drexco's raised!
Where is you shooting?
Dude!
Jesus.
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
Exactly as you ordered, boss.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
I survived.
I survived the battle of Red Cliff.
That should be on my shirt.
I did not know better, I would say.
Yes, indeed.
Your presumption is on the mark.
My allegiance is with them.
Oh my God, I did it.
Farewell, Shishu.
I hope we can meet again someday.
That's fucking right.
Run!
Run, you bitch!
That's right!
I'm taking back my base, too!
I really changed to make the fire attack possible.
Lord Chugoyang must be some kind of sorcerer attack.
I survived the battle and all I got was a lousy shit.
I will come to be known, not as a strategist, but as a...
I'm just happy it's over.
I'm so relaxed now.
I'm so... I'm so relaxed after that.
Like, holy fuck.
Well, my part here is done.
I must go now...
Oh my God.
...to plan for the next battle.
Wait, I'm gonna kill you.
We gotta make it real so people don't know you betrayed us.
We gotta make this real, bro!
So people won't know!
Neither flame nor sword has been defeated.
There we go.
So, these chains were part of the enemy's plan.
Then, we'll need to remove them quickly.
Wait, is the game volume a bit low?
Wait, that's...
Shoot, it's the same volume I used before.
I'll boost it up a little.
That's weird.
Okay, let me double check.
Dynasty...
Warriors...
Is that the same one I used?
Yeah, it's the same...
Volume I always use for Dynasty Warriors.
That's weird if it's a bit low.
But I boosted it up.
I boosted it a little bit higher.
Alright.
Oh!
The sound guy is here and can let me know.
Also, it might be the mic thing, too.
Preventing further sacrifices is my top priority now.
Alright, let's kill him.
That's right, I came over to beat your ass!
You can just avoid the flames.
All is not yet lost.
I wasn't.
Oh my god.
We lost so many generals.
This is where we make our stand.
We're moving towards the North Bank?
Why are you going to the North Bank?
Oh my god!
Our morale is so high!
Where are we going?
I don't even know where...
I never thought we'd get this far!
I never thought we'd get this far.
Where do I go now?
Many of the ships are burning down.
You need to make sure we take the right path forward.
Would you?
Alright.
Please honor me in a duel.
I have nothing but reservations about fighting you.
Who wants to duel me?
I'm ready!
What should I withdraw?
We gotta make this look real, bro.
We got...
We know you betrayed, but...
We gotta make this look real!
Or tell no!
So...
We're gonna hang back here.
Alright.
Nice.
I don't think they know that we...
I don't think he knows.
Okay, let me get rid...
I won't get rid of all these bosses, Chris.
Nice acting, bro.
Okay.
And then...
Get out of here!
That's right!
I had to grind off stream!
That's fucking right!
Our allies are doing well.
Keep it going.
That's what you guys get!
I like how...
Oh.
The game audience is a bit too loud now?
Okay.
Alright.
Let me fix it again.
I'll fix it again, guys.
Alright.
There we go.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
How...
I need to know how to get over to the other side.
Oh, I should have followed my team.
I...
I should have followed my team!
How do I get to the other side?
To form the perfect plan.
There's nothing more...
I can do here!
This way...
And then...
Oh my god.
They're ready to charge.
And I got distracted.
They're like, We're ready!
We're just waiting for you right now!
And I'm like, Okay.
I feel like...
That I was not paying attention.
But I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
I'm almost...
Okay.
I went the wrong way.
Don't worry.
I'm almost there.
Alright.
Okay.
It looks like south-south forces are gathering on the northern coastline.
Do you need to wait for me?
We must be prepared.
Wait!
Please!
The fire attack was very effective.
The enemy must be exhausted.
Wait for me!
If we all work together, victory will be ours.
Okay.
One guy.
You really had us deceived.
Oh, I think I meant I went the wrong way.
I'm gonna make a fool out of me.
Oh, wait!
Wait!
It's time for us to finish this.
I'm going to Suquan!
Give me a sec!
I'm so ready!
Alright.
Wait.
How did he...
How did he get there?
Oh, it's this way!
Suquan, wait!
I almost fucked it up!
I'm a little lost!
I'm ready.
Let's go!
Slaughter!
Me and...
NPC number one.
This is what we've been waiting for.
It's a little awkward.
It's a little awkward that...
I can sort of like...
Okay, let's see.
So what am I going to do?
It's a little awkward that like, I went with the like, NPC guys.
Instead of like, you know, my actual team.
And like, that's alright.
These turbulent times dictate such things.
Nice.
I can't see anything.
But nice.
Jesus Christ, there's so many people.
Wait.
It's time!
I shall be a real warrior now.
Ice Strike!
Show them our unity.
Oh shit, what did he do?
Oh, defeat.
Oh, that's easy.
Did I do it?
I think...
I think that's it, right?
No.
Wait.
How did I not get 300 after that?
Oh, whoa.
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh, I did it.
Don't worry.
It was just catching up.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Oh my god.
Everybody's...
They're all just dead.
Holy fuck.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Nice.
I don't know how...
Guys, everybody just dies.
That was crazy.
Okay.
Okay, he just said he can't lose.
I don't believe.
Oh fuck!
Okay.
I need to kill him.
He's literally one HP.
Come on.
You're so close to dying!
Come on!
Yes!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Take this!
Alright, I need to kill all these guys for extra.
What?
Okay, that's...
Oh my god!
I got it!
Jesus Christ, you fucker.
You fucker!
That's right!
Get your Musou out of here!
We're fighting a losing battle.
Oh, no.
Oh, I dodged it.
What do you mean?
How did you guys all die?
Oh no.
Okay.
Come on!
Is Musou so close?
Just one more hit!
Nice!
Oh!
Fifteen seconds!
Let's go close!
Oh!
Alright!
Chao Chao, it's just you!
All your friends are dead!
You made me level up off stream, you fucker!
Get out of here!
Boom!
Easy!
It's not like this fight took me like...
A whole day...
To fucking...
Finish!
Oh my god!
This fucking fight!
Oh!
I'm so happy it's over!
It's so easy!
Easy!
Oh!
King Lee is hanging in there!
Finally!
King Lee has already put a new plan into place!
We should begin our pursuit as well!
Holy fuck!
I'm so happy!
Jesus Christ!
That level fucking...
Like I love Battle of Redcliff!
Or Battle of Chibi!
But...
Jesus!
Oh my god!
That was so...
That was so intense!
I literally have to run left!
Run right!
Run left!
I have to...
Junkle!
Left and right!
Kill one boss!
Go to the left side!
Kill two!
Go to the right!
Watch four people die!
Go to the left side!
And...
Jesus!
It was hell!
I...
It was...
It was actual hell!
Oh my god!
My horse leveled up from all that too!
Nice!
Alright!
Defense!
Strength!
I need...
I need strength!
One last battle!
One final battle chat!
Is that?
What did the wind change?
The stupid fucking wind!
Fifty-four!
Druid P heeeet All right.
I don't understand.
You can only use one of these medicines, too.
That's the most fucked up part.
All right, I want to see if there's any... I'll make sure if there's any, like, any romance in my Three Kingdoms.
Oh,
no one?
It's the last battle!
I can't believe it!
No one wants to talk to me on the final battle?
What was it all for?
I can't believe no one wants to talk to me!
I thought we had something!
Oh, my God.
After everything we've been through?
Okay, we gotta go...
I guess we'll go here.
We've been through so much together!
Where's...
Where's my last...
My last interaction?
Yeah.
I have the Oblivion gem equipped, which is good.
Is it because I let them die?
Is that it?
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
It's burning!
Holy fuck!
Jesus!
Okay, I like that.
The little touch that they did.
Ah!
Okay.
Is this battle harder than QB?
We'll find out.
Let's find out.
About the same?
The resolve of Wu's officers is laudable indeed.
And yet, the thread of Cao Cao's life has yet to be severed.
It would seem he means to converge with his rearguard from Huarong Path.
That is why I have tasked Lords Zhao Yun, Zhang Fei, and Guan Yu to lie in wait and ambush him.
I need you to pursue Cao Cao and pin him between you and those three.
Don't worry, I got this.
But I'm also going to grab Guan Yu with me.
Now then.
Let's see what our next move is.
Yansuke, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can try to bribe Peng Tong to help finishing his friend mission.
I did!
He won't!
Oh, I can grab Guan Yu, but I did!
He won't take my money!
I bribed all of them!
Liu Bei's forces...
He won't take my money!
This...
is all part of the Long Zong plan.
I don't understand.
I have so much money to spend just for host club.
Giant Fei and Xiao Yun are in position.
I don't understand.
Wait, where am I pursuing...
Here?
I assume it's here, right?
Which way?
I don't know which way!
Instructions are clear!
Which way was I supposed to go?
I should have paid attention in school.
I'm sorry, Drew Gotler.
I wasn't really listening to be fair on which way you wanted me to pursue.
Open the door!
You will not escape me!
Prepare to die, TaoTao!
Oh, I could have went the other way.
Oh, well, I'm already here.
I should have paid attention to him.
Okay, I just made it.
Okay.
Ice!
Nice!
Okay, we gotta get rid of this base.
How is there still people?
Oh, they're all over here.
Why are you guys in the corner?
Your leader died!
Oh my god, whoops.
Open the door!
It is well worth the effort to reorganize our forces so quickly.
Oh, I should have went the other way.
Okay.
Please, make your way up the mountain path.
I should have...
Guys, I should have went the other way, guys.
I...
The other way might have been faster, guys.
I am the impenetrable shield.
Wait, do I...
Do I even fight them?
Even a thousand glows would be enough to break my guard!
Oh, shit!
No, I wasn't!
I'm sorry, I got distracted!
No shield is big enough to withstand its wrath!
Sorry, I got distracted!
I'm coming over!
I finally made it.
Now...
I can...
Don't worry, I'm coming over for real this time.
You, Tao Tao.
I'm coming over!
In the hands of Chang-fei!
Open the door!
I'll open it myself!
That's right!
So...
You've been lying in wait all along.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
Still...
No matter how strong you are, I will not be impeded.
Don't worry, I'm here now!
Sorry, I got distracted, but I'm here!
We're going after Tao Tao.
Don't worry!
Sorry!
I totally did not get distracted doing this.
Oh my god.
It's okay, I got Fred.
Oh, yes, let's go.
Wait, I didn't even say yes.
He just demanded it.
This can't be...
What happened?!
What?!
He just... he hit me!
Bro!
Bro, this one guy is blocking me.
What the f...
Bro just...
Bro just slapped me and I died!
He's so cool.
Bro, he actually...
He just fucking slapped me and it was over!
Like, what the fuck was I supposed to do?!
I don't even know what I was supposed to do there!
Please continue onward.
I will keep the enemy officer...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many things.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna save my...
I'm gonna save my thing.
Just in case he does that again.
No, no, no, no!
No!
Okay.
Okay, round two.
But a different guy now.
Okay, I blocked it.
Easy.
I'm just gonna keep my energy thing.
Because like, I...
I'm scared.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's not as bad as whatever the fuck Shaohu didn't try to do to me.
Cause that was fucking scary.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, we got him out of the way.
Wait, what?
He like, just left me?
I was having a fight with one of his...
I'm getting out of here.
That's right, I'm here.
I need to charge up my thing.
I need to charge this up.
Just in case.
I even think he was a super chat.
I'm just making sure I have like...
Half the...
Enough of the counter.
In case he does that again.
I'm scared.
I'm too scared.
Jesus Christ!
This is where we make our stand.
What just happened?
We must be ready to die.
Oh my god.
I don't wanna use my special attack just in case it happens again!
You must deal with the enemy quickly and forge ahead.
Just starting.
Alright.
Help you surround it if I'm not careful.
Please.
Change course and head south.
I'm so scared, I'm so scared, I'm so scared.
Now for our second stroke.
Oh my god.
Please!
Okay, I have enough.
I have enough.
I have enough to stop it.
Take this.
Oh.
Easy.
Okay.
Good job!
Doki.
Doki this is what killed me.
Like that move is what killed me.
That move is so fucking scary.
Like...
I need to always have enough just to counter that one move.
Take this.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I'm not scared anymore.
There's a different escape point?
Wait, where did he go?
What?
Wait, he, like, ran.
Oh, my God.
He used him as bait?
Okay, but, like, I want to kill him first.
I like how... I can't believe it!
He used him as bait!
That's so smart!
Wait, I can change?
All right.
Okay.
Nice.
It's time to meet Jonfei.
All right.
I'm gonna use this.
Okay, I thought he would stop.
I don't know why.
I just stopped.
I... for some reason, I thought he would stop and wait.
I don't know why I expected that.
The arrival of the reinforcements is as predicted.
Continue your pursuit of it's outside while crushing any enemies in the past.
Oh, no!
Like, you know, to watch the 1v1?
I thought he would watch the... I thought he would want to watch the 1v1.
finally ready for our Lord's arrival.
Hmm.
This is a miracle that he has made it this far already.
Welcome to this.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Okay.
Okay, he might be, like, a little on high ground, but I still got him.
Everything depends on this moment.
Whoa!
We must see our Lord to safety.
Take this.
Lord Saltao, keep going.
Okay, we got him.
All right, we need him.
The enemy counter has been defeated.
A man of your strength will survive to stand at my side again.
Don't worry!
I... I can make it!
I can make it!
Don't worry!
Tsuko Young has predicted their every move thus far.
Let's go!
His insight is incredible.
Okay, not this way.
I can make it.
Don't worry, guys.
Okay, I need these jars, though.
We're fighting Tsau-Tsau's forces on our own.
Will this put us on equal footing with who?
I'm almost there.
This plan has taken every detail into account.
Nubi's got this!
I believe!
All that remains is for me to carry out my part in it.
Okay, that side, I...
You know when they said, like, oh, yeah, they, like, blocked it?
I... For some reason, I didn't think they actually blocked it.
I...
Come on.
And of course, Liu Bei is my final obstacle.
Let's go.
I'm heading over.
All those with the strength to enforce their will...
Come on.
Come on, little guy!
You've got this!
Today, we fight to clear a path for tomorrow!
Come on, my horse!
We're almost there!
He's so close!
What?
Liu Bei...
Somehow I knew it would be you standing in my way.
But it will gain you nothing.
Excuse me?
What about me?
You will not end my rule!
Lord Cao Cao.
What did he do?
I have gathered the strength and the will to stand against you.
He just shows up!
It is time for our final battle.
Oh, Liu Bei.
Who?
We all know Liu Bei was the one that stopped this entire fight.
The rest is up to you.
Up to you.
That's right.
Who's on standby?
I'm literally fighting right now!
Who the fuck is on standby?
Who's charging right now?
Forward as a lord.
We will win this deck.
And we will share our dream with the world.
Concentrate.
Alright.
Get iced.
Get iced!
Okay, where is he?
Wait, where's Cao Cao?
Oh!
Okay, that's not Cao Cao.
Where is he?
Oh, wait!
Oh shit!
I shall retreat now.
See that I might fight again another day.
Where is he?
What the hell?
Honor me in a duel.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Let me duel you!
I will prove the strength of my hero.
Oops, I missed.
Oh, I missed again.
It's okay.
I used strength.
Lord Guan Yu, this battle is in your hands.
Okay.
We must win for the sake of Lord Nubei's dream for the world.
Holy shit!
There's so many of them!
I am well aware of what's at stake.
Jesus!
They're all just trying to fucking beat me up!
Oh my god!
The enemy's formation is beginning to fall apart.
It's just all bosses!
We can break through!
It's just all bosses.
It's really just all bosses.
It's all bosses.
Oh my god!
This brings me back to when we first met.
Okay, you guys...
You guys deal with these bosses over here.
I'll deal with Cao Cao.
Our sense of duty and honor has not changed since.
Nice.
For now, to Liu Bei we have a great lord will the enemy officer.
Oh my god!
He's one HP.
Nice.
With every strike Okay, wrong way!
Wrong way, guys!
Wrong...
Wrong way!
I swear to god, if these guys killsteal me.
I swear to god...
It's fine.
I'll...
I'm okay with kill stealing.
I'm...
I'm okay!
As long as it's Gwanyun, I'm okay.
We ended on Gwanyun.
The real main character.
Gwanyun with the kill-sicker.
That's why he's a god of war.
We did it.
Oh my god.
We finally did it.
Holy fuck.
What a large step it will be.
Looking rough.
Oh my god, we did it.
It's over.
Go, Lord Tau Tau.
You won't cut me down.
It's looking over.
You saved the lives of people dear to me and my brother.
And so I owe you a deep debt of gratitude.
Disregarding that would not be a righteous act.
And would not lead towards the future my brother dreams of.
Still, remember well Tau Tau.
One day.
The Yubei will surely surpass you.
I like naturally.
Oh Gwanyun.
You are so foolish.
I shall not allow that.
My triumph over him is inevitable.
With this, I have repaid my debt.
Ah, it's you.
You should have cut him down.
I disagree.
It was for the best.
Lord Chuga Lian dispatched me to this place precisely.
Because he knew I wouldn't cut down Lord Tau Tau.
You idiot!
Now Tau Tau Tau would definitely not win!
If you guys, now you will be the next to the world of your strength.
And if that happens, the long song plan shall not come to pass.
The future and freedom of our people is at stake here.
Although the world is wrought with turmoil, my brother still shines as a guiding light of righteousness.
You fool!
And although many have perished along the way, their sacrifices will not be in vain.
All we can do now is strive to realize the long song plan.
Trusting that it will bring us closer to achieving my brother's dream.
I shall not allow him to lose sight of what he cherishes.
That is, above all, my duty and privilege.
But we will need your strength.
After all, turning such dreams into reality will be no small feat.
Oh my god, you fool!
You've doomed us all, Gwonyun!
You've doomed the kingdom!
It could have been the Romance of the Two Kingdoms!
Now you've made it three!
He's like, yeah, but this sound is good.
Three sounds better than two.
And thus, Cao Cao's fleet sank into a sea of flames.
Wu was vitalized by a strategic advantage.
Their energy was matched by Cao Cao's pure strength.
Liu Bei gained control of the Jing province.
The first great step on the path of realizing Zhukot Lun's Longzheng plan.
The age of the Three Kingdoms.
No!
Now you brought forth the Three Kingdoms!
We could have been two!
And that's how five Seema are you after!
You fool!
But brother, Threeu sounds so much better!
There's a lot to take care of after that battle.
So you may as well rest up today.
Are you sure that's okay?
Come on now.
Don't be like that.
Kick your feet up now.
You'll need the rest for the fighting to come.
You ought to take time to relax now and again.
Why have two when you can have three?
Ancient China was just too big for Two Kingdoms.
Everyone enjoying their own pursuits.
Without the threat of some battle on the horizon.
This might be exactly what brother is aiming for.
You're right.
That's why it's three brothers.
That's why I got ridden out.
Three brothers are better than four.
I knew it!
Rules of three!
He likes the rules of three.
Oh, but perfect timing.
Didn't expect to see all of you here.
Sorry, but could you lend a hand?
A bear has appeared in the fields.
A bear?
This is Red and Bear doing.
Leave it to me.
Even this may be part of the first step toward accomplishing our dream.
What?
Killing a bear?
There you are.
The four of us were just talking about you.
Me?
Without a doubt.
Your deeds in the last battle were heroic.
That's me.
According to military regulations, you must be rewarded with a rank and command befitting your achievements.
Then again, your ability to act freely is your strong point, isn't it?
I get the feeling a position like this wouldn't suit you all that well.
Well, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
We discussed it among ourselves, but could not come to a consensus in the end.
That is why we would like you to choose.
First, there is the path of the general and a life of public prominence.
You may find yourself feeling a bit more stifled than you do now.
Still, the fame and standing a generalship provides is well worth it.
Or, you may support us from the shadows without an official position.
Wait a minute.
You may find this role somewhat lacking in benefits.
Yeah.
But, in exchange, you can maintain...
Wait, they're trying to write me out!
You'll hear no objections from us.
Wait!
Wait a minute.
They're trying to write me...
They're trying to write me on history!
They don't even want me to join them anymore!
I wish them...
I won the fame.
You can't write me out.
That's fucking right.
I want me a general.
Like...
You can't write me out.
I deserve credit!
It's four brothers!
This is...
A good choice, I believe.
Having you take up a command grants me no small measure of reassurance.
Well, this is promising, isn't it?
I'm gonna write my own book.
I'll write my own romance of the four kingdoms.
You ask much of me, Jonfei.
I have my own kingdom.
That said...
I do owe you a great deal.
I will have to think of something...
That reflects my trust in you.
Oh, there's my...
There's my child doctor.
How can I ever thank you enough for curing my father of that dreadful disease?
It is I who should be thanking you.
Your request allowed me to gain yet another valuable experience as a doctor.
And I am always glad to be of service.
Please tell him to take care of himself as he recovers.
I will.
Um...
By the way...
Master Yuanhua.
Do you plan on leaving town already?
Yes, I do.
I've received word that my companion is waiting for me outside the castle.
But...
I am not really sure where we will be going next.
And with that, I bid you farewell.
Wait, he still follows me?
I hope you never need to see me again.
I...
Okay, he's just living off of my free rent.
Like...
He still...
He still follows me around?
Master Yuanhua!
Please, wait!
Like, he's just mo...
He's just leeching!
He's a freeloader!
Didn't I just say...
I hope you never need to see me again?
Is something wrong?
Have I...
Left something behind, perhaps?
No, it's just...
Just what?
Oh my god, now I have to take care of another guy?!
Prentice...
I've already discussed it with my father.
You're the only one who made a real effort to treat him when...
Every doctor in town gave up.
And you were the one to finally cure him.
Watching you do that, it...
Changed me, as a man.
I told my father.
Imagine if I could become a doctor like him!
Oh my god, now I have two freeloaders!
I once would have dismissed the idea...
As undeserved flattery.
But...
Yes...
Perhaps it's not such a bad idea.
I do need someone to inherit all of the wisdom and knowledge passed down to me after all.
Then you...
You could have your own son!
I...
I will accept you as my new apprentice.
But no...
When you want to pass down to someone with your blood?
Or how much?
Thank you so much, Master Yuanhua!
Oh, uh...
Yuanhua is your courtesy name, isn't it?
I think I should know the true name of someone who's to be my mentor.
Would you mind telling it to me?
Oh...
Why does he get his own cutscene?
He was not that important.
My name is...
It's Huatuo.
Please, call me Hua Yuanhua.
Oh my...
Wait, Huatuo?
Huatuo.
Sorry.
Who is...
That's so familiar.
That...
That name is so familiar.
I'm trying to...
I am a bird with no wings.
Dashed against the earth.
Blood clouds my sight.
Is he...
He's the famous doctor.
The fact that he didn't even ask for my permission.
To have a third...
To have a second freeloader living with me.
And thereby stirs the whole-consuming flames of war.
Even if peace lies at the end of his path...
Will it be worth it?
Oh, he's a...
He's a legendary...
Oh, that's him!
Still eludes me.
Still...
Liu Bei...
Is the hero you have chosen.
And you have decided...
To carry on Juha's dream...
For the future.
So for now...
I'll be watching you.
And hoping that the path you choose...
Fucking most famous...
Chinese doctor...
But yet still won't pay for rent.
Will bring peace to our world.
That's so paced!
He pays...
What medical treatment?
He lights an incense...
And then I go...
I go through a bad trip.
That's his medical treatment for me.
You have found your path.
You found comrades to accompany you.
Oh...
My dead wife.
You're certain to reach it.
A land of peace.
That's why he doesn't chase after any other woman.
Because no other woman can live up to his dead wife.
That's why he chases ancient Chinese generals.
Sorry, I ruined the moment.
I'm sorry.
I...
I might have ruined the moment there.
Um...
Thank you.
Super chat.
First general anesthesiologist in China.
Use my face on.
Thank you.
That's super chat.
Oh my god.
We finally finished.
It took us four months.
We finally finished Dynasty Warriors.
Oh my god.
I heard like...
The other stories would be a lot easier, right?
Because like they don't scale...
They don't scale the levels, do they?
Or new game plus.
But you start back at...
Level one.
Oh, but we're finished.
We finished one story.
One story.
On the YouTube channel.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
You start from your first level.
But do they...
Do they scale the level?
I can make it...
I'm not scaling it.
I'm not...
I'm not redoing.
I'm not scaling the level and making it harder for myself against Lubu.
I...
I'm not...
I'm not making it harder.
I'm s...
I'm gonna make sure I one-shot people.
Um...
But yes, the future playthroughs of Dynasty Warriors will be on Twitch now.
I don't know when on Twitch, but I'll definitely...
I'll put it on a schedule.
Whenever I play...
I'm gonna take a little break from Dynasty Warriors before we do...
Uh...
Wei or En-Wu.
Um...
I'm gonna leave Chao Chao's storyline for last.
Just cause I feel like Chao Chao's storyline is like...
The most important storyline...
To end it off of.
Because he's the last kingdom to survive.
In a way.
Technically...
Technically, Sun Quan's kingdom survived the latest.
But only because like...
He didn't really do anything...
After that.
Like...
Cause like...
Chao Chao's kingdom just got taken over by Si Ma Yi.
And then like...
Like the Red Kingdom just like...
Existed.
Because nothing really happened for them.
Um...
But like...
Story-wise...
I think...
It's best to end with Chao Chao.
Um...
Yeah, he won by doing nothing.
Like...
Yeah, so I'm definitely saving Chao Chao's story at last.
But...
It was really fun!
Uh...
Sorry, I spoiled a...
How many years ago?
Like...
500 plus year old story.
For you guys!
Um...
But...
It was fun!
I'm so happy to play...
Dynasty Warriors with all of you guys.
Um...
Going through the storylines.
Going through...
Um...
Everything.
Like...
Playing...
The full game.
And enjoying like...
The history lesson.
And...
Uh...
Enjoying, you know...
Um...
My favorite characters.
And you know...
Going to my Dynasty Warriors host club every night.
Um...
Once a week.
Every night.
Not this week though.
Unfortunately.
I can't believe...
They closed the host club.
I'm so sad.
I can't believe it.
They closed my Dynasty Warriors host club.
I'm so sad.
They won't let me talk to my favorite Chinese generals.
I...
How could they do this to me?
They made me progress the plot.
I can't believe it.
I have to progress the plot.
And play...
The...
The side quest.
Play the mini game.
Instead of the main story line.
Date of birth and death unknown.
Officer in service of Lube.
The distinct color of his eyes.
And his radiant sash that resembles the tail feathers of the sacred bird.
Garnered him the name too long.
He began his journey as a wandering warrior who fought for coin.
However, he became acquainted with Lube.
During the early days of the volunteer army.
And after the relationship deepened.
Over time.
He eventually decided to officially serve under Lube.
He feels his feats in the suppression of Yan prophets were especially noteworthy.
It is said that he defeated 3,997 enemies there.
Not 4,000.
Wow.
Wow, Doki.
I can't believe you're washed now.
Although he was known for his reticent nature.
He got along very well with Guan Yun.
I like how it's specifically named Guan Yun too.
It's said that the two of them trusted each other deeply.
Ooh.
And Fade to Black.
And fought together in many battles.
Not Doki's greatest achievement was carved into the islands of history at the Battle of Chibi.
There, he sensed this very unlikely onset of the southern easterly wind that enabled the fire-eye attack to succeed.
Thus contributing to one of the greatest victories ever recorded.
Not Doki was renowned for his stalwart presence on the battlefield.
His guard in battle was as strong as the shell of the divine turtle.
He was terrified called the General of Defense.
Yet they don't even know when I fucking died.
Like...
Just like the bare minimum.
Didn't even bother to ask for my birthday.
Candid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pretty sure in Romance of the Three Kingdom, Hwa Tua tried curing Tau Tau's migraines.
Which were a brain tumor, probably.
And we couldn't do it.
Tau Tau had him executed.
So you probably don't have to support him long.
Yippee!
That's on him!
He's the one that decided to fucking try and help Tau Tau of all people.
Holy fuck.
That's on him.
We did it!
Oh my god!
We fucking did it, guys!
I can't believe it!
We actually made it to the end.
Zonderman!
Thank you to the super chat!
Thank you!
You should totally try it.
Wulong, Fallen Dynasty.
Totally accurate.
Very dumb.
Thank you to the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
We fucking...
I told you we'd finish it.
You know what?
We deserve a short stream today.
We had...
Like, Saturday's gonna be a very long day for me.
And then, uh...
With Fanime...
Fanime...
And also my sponsor.
And, um...
Friday...
Friday, obviously, I'm gonna be raging a lot.
With the Simpsons game.
So, like...
I deserve this one.
I deserve this one as my chill game today.
My chill short stream today.
And I played, like...
The...
Yesterday and the day before.
I did a very long...
The...
Two very long streams.
So...
Oh!
It was a nice day.
Nice day to finish the game.
I feel like we haven't finished the game in a long time.
So...
Ian!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Good job, Toki!
Yeah, it's been a long time since we finished the game.
So, like...
I'm happy with our progress.
I wonder!
We were sort of held hostage for a long time.
But, like...
Um...
I liked it.
I consented to being held hostage by Dynasty Warriors Origins.
My channel might not have consented.
My channel might have been, like, slowly dying because of it.
But that's okay.
But...
That's okay.
Because it's over now.
It's over.
Anyway...
Um...
But anyway, guys...
It was great.
Completing Dynasty Warriors.
I had a great time playing, um...
The Shoe Kingdom storyline for all of you guys.
Now it's time.
You're right.
Now it's time for Sandland part.
Now it's time to start Yakuza!
I've been thinking for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're free now.
Now it's time for Sandland part 2.
Or better yet...
Let me pull up what's the longest JRPG game out there.
But thank you everybody for watching.
I'm gonna head off now.
Um...
Because like I said...
I'm gonna take this as like...
A short day today.
Um...
But thank you all for watching.
I always appreciate it guys.
Hang out with me.
Um...
We finally completed Dynasty Warriors after so long.
So I really appreciate it guys.
Say goodbye to left side Doki.
Cause she's gonna...
I'm gonna send her to the farm downstate.
Um...
I'm gonna ship her to America and send her to a farm downstate there.
Uh...
But...
She'll be okay.
I like how I'm talking to myself in third person.
Um...
Sorry.
Right side Doki took control of me for a sec.
But I'll be okay.
Right side Doki said it's a good farm.
Uh...
Right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Darkblade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But since you're a big fan of Warriors games.
What are your thoughts of the Warriors spin-out game?
Like Zelda, Fire Emblem, Persona?
Um...
I tried to play the Zelda one.
But like...
I wasn't...
I got really bored of it.
Because I'm not like...
I think like...
Hack and Slash is more fun.
When you are like...
Know the story and the lore behind it.
So I don't really know much about Zelda games.
Because I never grew up with Zelda games at all.
Um...
When I...
My very first Zelda game I've ever played...
Was the train one.
So...
I don't know how I keep...
Getting started into like...
The worst versions of like...
Certain games.
And so like...
The train one...
The spirit tracks was my very first Zelda game...
Ever.
Um...
So like...
And I think that was...
My only Zelda game...
I've ever played.
So like...
I didn't understand...
The lore at all.
With like...
Zelda...
Zelda games.
And...
Why...
I mean like...
The lore is very simple.
Like...
Link gets a sword...
And then he has to defeat Ganondorf.
Like...
That's basically the lore of everything.
The general gist of things.
But like...
Still I like...
Didn't really have...
Any...
Knowledge of the characters.
Or like...
I didn't have any like...
Personal connection with the characters...
Or like knowledge of the characters.
So like the Zelda...
Warriors one...
Um...
Was...
Was like...
You know.
I don't know who people were...
Other then...
Link...
So I didn't find it that fun.
So I never...
I only played like...
A little bit.
I never played more after that.
Um, so I think I've only played the Zelda Warriors.
I think you'd like... you would like the Warriors series and the Hack and Slash series if you know the storyline and the characters.
So that's like my opinion for it.
So that's why I really like Dynasty Warriors because I grew up with the story and I grew up with the lore behind it and all the Dynasty Warriors games as well.
So that's why I really like... I really like this game in general.
Even when they retell the story like 800 times, I would still play it because I just love the story in general.
And I don't mind... Like, they can retell it so many times, and I'll pay $80.
I enabled them.
You know that Borderlands director was like, yeah, you'll make it work.
She's talking to me.
But for Dynasty Warriors, fuck Borderlands.
If the Dynasty Warriors director said that exact same thing to me, I'd buy it.
I'd be like, yeah, I'll buy it.
If it was a Dynasty Warriors director, I'd be like, yeah.
But no, that's really fucked up that the Borderlands director said that.
That's really fucked up.
It's like, you know, you have phones, right?
Like, it's basically like that.
That's just so tone-deaf of him.
Like, I made it work.
I saved up $80 to buy it.
Like, you can make it work if you like Borderlands.
But if the Dynasty Warriors director said the exact same thing, I'd be like, you're right.
But because I don't care about Borderlands that much, I'm like, that's fucked up.
Xeon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Spirit Tracks was peak.
You take that back.
I'm pretty sure I have a lot of people in chat that's willing to, like, go on a huge...
Ready to write a Google Doc about you.
A Google Doki.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We will miss you, left side, Doki.
Orca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why play Zelda when Link is on the stream I'm watching right now?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.